I feel like finding out this series was
even gonna happen it's like well it's
like the great conjunction what's the
great conjunction big change sometimes
good sometimes bad we got the good
version the Dark Crystal age of
resistance I it's funny to me that this
isn't this is gonna come out like four
days or so after I shoot it I burned
through this series in a weekend in
which it I mean that's not super
uncommon for me I've done that with
stuff before but usually stuff is
shorter than this usually if I burn
through something like that it's usually
you know the half hour shows something
that's gonna take me five hours tops
altogether to watch this is this is
between nine and ten hours so this is a
this is a bit for me to burn through as
quickly as I did and it should tell you
quite a bit the prequel to the cult
classic film The Dark Crystal
now I enjoyed the Dark Crystal quite a
bit with some reservations you can see
my review of the full thing from a
little bit ago but the short version is
I think the design of the original film
is amazing I think the puppetry is
incredible I think the world that is
created is astounding I think the
storyline is pretty standard heroic
journey epic fantasy kind of stuff and I
think Jen is quite possibly at the very
least he's on the shortlist for a
nomination for the most useless
protagonist in the history of fantasy
fiction he's really really just useless
there's no other word for him I don't
like Jen a lot at all but so much else
about it is so
so good so it was definitely something
worth revisiting and I'm really really
glad they did now I was nervous about
the notion of a prequel for the same
reason I'm always nervous about the
notion of a prequel how much of this is
predetermined how much do we already
know how this is going to end and there
is a bit of that here but it has an
interesting outcome the and the first is
is that really if you think about the
Dark Crystal it's like the last chapter
watching the original Dark Crystal is
like reading the last few chapters of a
book without having read anything that
came before you can infer a lot you can
get a lot from context but you're like
I'm missing big chunks of this it's not
quite in media res it it does have a
completed story are you know again built
around useless but the in terms of the
world there's it feels like there's so
much you could be learning that you
haven't so it's a world that definitely
lends itself to expansion including from
prior to the events of the Dark Crystal
film because you can't really set much
after I mean you could but given the
resolutions like I feel like that should
that should be the end so a pretty cool
a lot always makes sense that said there
it there are still the issues of well we
know what the opening set up was for the
film which means there's some fairly
significant things that were like we
kind of know what's is gone ahead and
normally that's more of a detriment here
it just it adds a certain vibe it adds a
certain melancholy to it that I think
actually enhances the tone of the thing
overall and I won't go into huge detail
on that just on the off chance that you
know people have gotten into the show
and I wouldn't see in the movie yet like
I don't know if those people exist but
hey maybe trying to be a comedy so I
avoid spoilers for as long as I can as I
usually tried to do so with your opening
set up we have the Skeksis in command of
the crystal and
of this world a called FRA it never got
named at the there's a number of things
that didn't get named in the original
film that get named and those names get
said a lot it's actually one of the
nitpicks I have I feel like they they
look for way too many opportunities to
say all the fantasy names like over and
over and over and over again but anyways
so we're here in the Skeksis are in
command of the crystal that is kind of
for lack of a more elegant and detailed
way to do but it's basically the beating
heart of this entire world they're in
control of it it keeps them alive but
it's also become corrupted over time now
when I say they rule this world actively
like they are the rulers the Lords and
the other races specifically the
gelfling z-- of which there are seven
clans though we only really deal with
three of them more we get a little bit
of some of those but primarily we're
only dealing with three of the clans in
this series they serve I mean they are
the subjects of the Skeksis and it does
create an interesting new dynamic where
the gelfling as a society don't realize
that the Skeksis are a problem at least
not at the start of the thing of course
you know for us the audience hey if
you've seen the movie B you know just
look at them of course they're come bad
guys holy crap what what else can you
say but we have that as a starting
premise and you basically deal with
three different gelfling protagonists in
three different locations from each of
the three main clans that would deal
with who sort of learn in through
different ways that Skeksis are a
problem and they're all they don't know
each other they're all in parallel but
eventually their stories have to
converge then they have to try and build
a resistance to what the Skeksis are
actually doing
so there's a lot to like about this as a
structure first of all the fact that
we've got the basically three primary
protagonists it means that instead of
ending of was somebody incredibly bland
like Jen who has to be kind of
everything they've gone for three more
specific protagonist archetypes but we
get to have all three so we have rien
who is you know sort of the the light
hearted guy you know he's he's a fighter
but he doesn't think his his duties all
that serious and he's actually a guard
at the castle of the Skeksis until
something happens and he has his eyes
open to what it is that he is in service
up is like oh oh all right so we've got
that we have a Brea who is very learning
very question questions that's or things
she has questions she always wants
answers and in her pursuit of generally
just trying to find stuff out she starts
to put some things together that makes
her realize oh crap and then there is
DEET and DEET comes from this clan that
lives underground they're very connected
to the world to the earth to the to
thraw to the various creatures and she
senses the corruption spreading they
call it the darkness I'm sorry the
darkening so it makes me think of the
quickening and Highlander and I just I
can't help but snicker a little bit but
the the darkening it becomes aware of
that and basically sets out to try and
figure out how to prevent the spread of
this thing and so you've got her working
on more of the cuz because she's lived
her whole life literally lived her whole
life underground and she comes up and so
she's a bit more the fish-out-of-water
who doesn't who is a little naive about
the world so you have you know you're
slightly jaded character with Rhian you
have you're more naive character with
Dee you've got your middle ground with
with Brea and like I said different sort
of archetypes for each of these three
protagonists and it balances really well
between the three of them I was fairly
impressed with that it's worth
mentioning at this point the
the voice cast is really good because
and it's quite a mix we've got a fair
number of people who basically get to
play completely original characters all
the gyal flings but we've got a number
of people who also need to basically
recreate in some way voice work from the
film and for me the standout there is
Simon Pegg voicing the Chamberlain the
Chamberlain's my favorite in this series
um yeah of the Skeksis he's so slimy and
smarmy and what I love about him more
than anything is he's a manipulator
that's what he does but at no point does
the show or even the Chamberlain as a
character try and sell him as sincere
nobody believes that this guy is not
always working his own agenda at all
times and yet he's able to convincingly
mess with people despite that there's uh
there's a specific scene later on that I
don't want to spoil this all to try and
keep vague he's he's talking to a
character that is in his custody and he
actually flat out gives that character
the chance to leave because you know
this concern this this character that he
has is gonna try to escape and he gives
them the chance limbs they go ahead run
away like you have been doing and every
time you do it people die and that cuts
this other character to the core and
they don't run and it's not that they
don't know that that the Chamberlain's
manipulating them they know but man he's
good at it I love him a lot but so we've
got all these you know great recreations
and of course the puppet the puppetry is
astounding and I'm gonna highly
recommend if you watch this you
basically immediately leap into watching
the making of feature documentary
feature it's about an hour
hour and a half watch that because if
nothing else it'll open up your eyes to
how little of this was CG there's some
obvious CG effects here and there but if
you watch the making of you realize Oh
some stuff that I had a sued was like
heavily CG was actually just a little CG
and still mostly puppets which is
freaking awesome and III also it's worth
also mentioning with the ghoul flings I
feel like they did a not a lot of nice
little tweaking and redesigned with the
gelfling is a little bit apparently been
to a certain degree there's a little bit
of CGI assistance to make them slightly
more expressive which is good because
that was another kind of one of the
slightly off things again mostly but Jen
not quite as much with Keira in the
original film which was that the
geldings because they have a more human
appearance the fact that they move so
stiffly feels a little more weird and a
little more off-putting that's not an
issue with things like the Mystics the
Skeksis the pod legs because they don't
look human but the couplings are close
enough that you you notice how stiff
they are the movement is a little bit
better in the face you know you get a
little bit more in the eyes that they
they have little tweaks to the mouth
that are probably more than could have
been done within animatronics um but not
so much where it suddenly like it feels
like a superimposed mouth effect or
anything like that it's really well done
incredibly subtly well done enough to
give more life to the ghoul flings as a
species and of the of the gelfling
characters throw pretty good Rianne I
prize probably the most generic for me
Bray is pretty good deets my favorite
out of the gelfling 's I like her a lot
we also get a lot of fun side characters
again voiced by some terrific actors you
have a very fun sort of Elder mystic
kind of gelfling character voiced by
Eddie Izzard which I had a lot of fun
with and there's some later voices that
turn up that I can't even really say who
the characters are because spoilers I
might have to start getting into
spoilers look if you enjoy
all-encompassing fantasy like complete
fantasy world know you must know nothing
just get him just dwell in this amazing
world for a while
watch
this the story is is a lot I would say I
significantly better than the Dark
Crystal
again when I say the story don't mean
the setting and the characters and the
lore I mean the narrative it's it's got
a lot more going on than the very
straightforward hero's journey story
that was the original film so that's a
nice thing as well I am gonna start
getting into spoilers because I want to
start talking specific things here and
there and like I've got little niggles a
little nitpick so I'll probably mention
in the spoilers section but like they
weren't enough to even slow me down
watching this thing I enjoyed the
ever-lovin heck out of it so getting
into spoilers a little bit one of my
more substantive complaints cuz I've got
little nitpicky things like one of the
CGI things that they do is they have the
tongues waggle in the Skeksis mouths and
I don't necessarily problem with them
doing it but they do it too much and
maybe it's maybe I would feel that way
if I wasn't so familiar with the
original film where their tongues did
not move like that and if I didn't have
that for reference maybe you wouldn't
bug me but it does for this that they
open their mouths in the tongues just
all over the place that was that was an
added CGI touch that I don't think was
necessary and for me didn't help so
there's little things like that but the
most substantive sort of thing is
augerin ow
all grow was my favorite character in
the original film and while they by no
means wrecked her character did anything
that she's very true to the
characterization we see in the original
film I don't really like the characters
use and the character's role in the
story now I'm not gonna say that they
like got it wrong because a big part of
the original Dark Crystal is if you're a
big fan of that you're dealing with a
lot of head canid because we get so few
concrete details about what this world
was before but when I read on our ground
a big part of what I always liked about
her was that she's a little bit nuts but
she happens to understand what is going
on
overall in this world probably better
than anybody else that's been taken a
bit further in this prequel where now
she's mother agra who basically was the
guardian of the planet and she's a much
more active force and I don't like that
as much I liked her a bit more being
just yeah she wasn't an active I always
read her as not being an active
participant in what was going on but
basically the only one with the most
pieces of the puzzle to understand what
it was she was an observer she wasn't
she wasn't a player and making her as
active a participant as this does I'm
Kylie oh okay it's not bad it's just to
do what I liked about the character it
doesn't play into you know sort of my
mind memory my vision my preference for
her but that's me and I have a feeling
I'm probably gonna be the only human
being on the planet with that particular
complaint but again I don't know I feel
like every time I say that other people
like oh no me too so maybe there's a
couple of us I don't know they do some
really interesting things because I they
they played interestingly with the fact
that we know all these golfing's are
gonna die that's kind of what I
mentioned at the front end being the the
foreknowledge giving in a sense of
melancholy um and like I found myself
debating would this play better if I
didn't know from the movie that the this
resistance was going to fail and it
actually doesn't play better or worse it
just plays different it's more hopeful
if you don't know that but I think the
story still has resonance it just shifts
into being a bit more of a oh you mm man
is this is gonna hurt
kind of a thing but it seems to have
enough self-awareness to not try and and
really sell it as a true triumph it has
that undercurrent of melancholy which
like with what happens with dete at the
end of the show kind of helps reinforce
as a gem
so that helps feed off the general vibe
of the thing we got some really they had
a lot of fun playing with Skeksis that
we hadn't seen because presumably well
in some cases we know but presumably
they're all dead at the start of the
film so we have characters like The
Heretic
and the collector I'm gonna use their
titles cuz I that was I mentioned before
about them over using the fantasy names
that the names of the Skeksis is is a
good example of that I really I will
always think of them by their roles not
their names so how often some of their
names got said annoyed me so for me
there the scientists the Chamberlain the
Emperor the gourmand yeah the the
general I you know they're those they're
not sketch or sketch mail or ya know but
anyways we got to see some Skeksis who
we've never seen before because they're
dead so we get The Heretic we get the
hunter um
and I figured I figured what was gonna
go with a hunter especially when we got
introduced the archer by okay so they're
paired off they're both gonna die on the
Heritage was a quite a cool idea thought
that was quite interesting
I suppose theoretically he doesn't have
to be dead him in his mystic other half
because they're so isolated they just
wouldn't be around so that I suppose
that's feasible in that case um but also
they sort of twist it because I assumed
the general was the same one who who
ends up succeeding the emperor in the
film the one that the Chamberlain has
the trial by Stone with but it's not
because he dies and that was a really
cool reversal and also had my single
favorite moment of the whole thing which
is the Chamberlain stabbing him and
going I'm going
you took my seat loved him so much
[Music]
of course I loved him he's the single
most Slytherin character on the entire
show of course I love him the Emperor
was also interesting because obviously
we only just saw him enough for him
dye and scar me for life by seeing that
when I was a kid I mentioned before how
that the image of the emperor in that
film that freaked me out again and still
gives me the willies he's just he's so
second hmm anyways um it's interesting
to get to know him um I jason isaacs
obviously that's great
casting Ferb for the voice on that um
hop-hop is probably my second favorite
character I look first of all I love
that we have now finally have a pod Ling
who is characterized as opposed to just
oh that means like the pilot I mean I
actually think were they before they
would have been made around the same
time you know not enough that one could
be accused of being a ripoff of the
other but the padding's feel very
reminiscent of the Ewoks in the in the
original film but to have one well
characterized and to have ambitions and
to have you know relationships and a
full personality of his own in Hub
that's great and I love him and I think
he's absolutely adorable that there is
an under utilization of his gigs in this
I mean I'll say that for myself but I
know I have to say that for Liz because
Fiske a by far is like her favorite
thing ever and she was super excited
when the first images of baffi which is
the fist gig with the eyepatch came out
and like she's at the time I'm recording
this she's still working away through
the show and I'm finished I'm like man
like she's gonna like this but the first
thing she's gonna tell me is there was
not enough his gig and this and she'll
also be right but I the second episode
two of his gigs barking at each other
that's like my favorite thing I didn't
know I needed like in this world this
world this world is so fully realized
and everything is so complete you feel
like you're witnessing entire ecosystems
and now an entire civilization with the
gelfling which we didn't have before we
didn't really we knew the Skeksis we
know the Mystics we knew gee
Chiara and a little bit about the
paddling's but we've got this entire
seven clan community we knew nothing
about before I really really do hope
this gets a second season but even if it
doesn't because I have no doubt this was
very expensive to make and even if it
doesn't get a second season where it
left is probably a good will probably
work and function but I really want to
see what else there is I want to I want
to see what other tricks this has up its
sleeve I want to find out what a bit
more about what's going on with DEET I
want I want to see the Chamberlain keep
scheming I want to see the got the
Gotham sorry the Gotham put to work I
just I want more time I want more time
in this world I have always wanted more
time in this world but you know what I
now have ten more hours worth of time in
this world I didn't have before and it
is clearly made by people with passion
who love the original and we're so
excited to be doing this and not it's
it's not retreading it's not about
trying to recapture what the original
was it is trying to bring whole new life
and whole elements to it they're not
reinventing the wheel they arte they are
taking the wheel and just building the
craziest friggin vehicle you've ever
seen out of it does that analogy even
work I don't know it's a little late I'm
a little tired but this was really
really good and if you haven't seen it I
hope you don't care about spoilers
because we're in the spoiler section at
this point but if you have seen it what
did you think about it whatever your
thoughts are shuffling down the comments
let's talk about it there's a bunch of
stuff too down to do down there as well
you can support me on patreon and help
keep this channel going help me pay my
bills even a dollar or a month helps
honestly a bunch of other stuff below
that besides my social media links and
my book if you want to buy that and all
sorts of stuff so going down give it a
click or
or don't I am NOT gonna tell you what to
do because at the end of the day you're
the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]